-My next guest is
an Emmy, Grammy,
and Tony-winning performer
who you can see in the third
and final season of "Pose,"
which airs Sundays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX.
Please welcome Billy Porter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Billy Porter ♪
♪ Everybody knows ♪
♪ You're shining like a star ♪
♪ When you strike a pose ♪
♪ Billy Porter ♪
♪ Casting a spell ♪
♪ On the audience ♪
♪ When you turn into Pray Tell ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-I knew it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm coming to "Fallon."
-Billy Porter, come on.
-I know you like my clothes.
I'm coming to "Fallon."
I call it Sissy Pimp.
[ Laughter ]
My Sissy Pimp look.
-I want to show you an Instagram
photo, because I follow you.
And you're a great follow.
This is you cleaning the pool.
[ Laughter ]
This is how Billy Porter
cleans his pool.
[ Laughter ]
-Please!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Listen. Listen.
That is a photo shoot
in Palm Springs.
It's Emilio Pucci realness.
-Okay.
-I didn't have a pool
when I shot that.
I do have a pool now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And somebody else cleans it!
-Oh, come on!
That's what I'm talking about!
-I don't clean the pool, kids!
I don't clean the pool.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk to you about
a bunch of things.
But I want to talk to you about
this "Hollywood Reporter"
article.
This was amazing, actually.
It was powerful.
It says, "This is what
HIV-positive looks like now."
-Yes.
-We all didn't know, obviously.
You were HIV-positive
for 14 years?
-Yeah, I've been positive
since 2007.
And, you know, having lived
through the AIDS crisis,
it was heavy for me.
It was a heavy year, 2007.
And I lived with the shame of it
for a really long time,
and last week,
I released that shame.
I released that trauma.
And I am a free man, honey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Free. Free.
-It feels good?
-Yes, it does. It does.
I've never -- I've never -- I've
never felt joy like this before.
And, you know, we talk about it
in the black church.
You know, this joy that I have,
the world didn't give it and
the world can't take it away.
I got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got some joy now.
-I'm so happy.
-You know, and it's just --
it really feels good.
It really feels great.
-I thought it was
very brave of you.
But also,
what an interesting story.
And I can't even imagine
how anyone would
just deal with that and just --
I mean, your mom -- you didn't
even tell your mother.
-No.
[ Laughs ]
That was the thing, you know.
It's, like, growing up
in the Pentecostal church,
there's such a stigma
surrounding it.
You know, having lived
through it, you know,
I was supposed to know better,
it happened anyway.
You know, there was just so much
going on, and my mother
received so much, you know,
persecution because I was gay.
And I just didn't want her to
have to go through that again.
It's sort of like
a second coming-out.
And I didn't want her
to go through that again,
and my sister and I had vowed
we were just going to wait
till she was dead.
And she went into a nursing home
six years ago,
and she ain't going nowhere.
[ Laughter ]
She's full of life!
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So it's time to tell her!
-Time to tell her, yeah.
-Time to tell her.
-I know you have --
Last time we talked,
you said you were
working on music?
-Yes.
-How's the music?
-New music, honey. New music.
-No, no. I want this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-For those of you
who don't know, you know,
I had a record deal
back in the '90s -- 1997.
My first R&B album came out
on A&M Records.
You know, they put
my gay ass out.
[ Laughter ]
So I did it anyway.
And now I'm coming back!
Daddy's coming back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
-Move out the way,
Ariana Grande, Beyoncé,
you know, Lady Gaga,
all the kids.
Just make some space for Daddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-I'm coming. Make some space.
-And you're recording right now?
-I'm recording right now.
I've been recording
for the last two months.
We got about 10 songs.
And I am so thrilled because,
you know, for the first time
in my life, it's exactly
what I want it to be.
The music is exactly from me,
what I want to say,
and the message, and the gift
that I want to
give to the world,
which is, you know,
hope, you know, love.
We have to choose it.
We have to recommit to it
every day.
We have to choose it,
so that we can fight,
you know,
the evil that is pervasive.
You know, we can only fight it
with love.
We can only do that.
It can only change with love.
And I'm so excited for my music
for that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We also talked about --
You're like,
"I'm just gonna work, work, work
during this pandemic."
And you said,
"I'm working on a memoir."
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
And I go, "How is the editing?
How is it going?
How is writing?"
You're like, "Great."
You brought to us tonight,
which I'm so thankful,
the cover of the memoir.
-You get a first look
of the cover!
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's done!
-Alright, here we go.
-The book is done!
-Ready?
-Ow!
Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that.
-Pre-order!
-I need the children
to pre-order.
-Pre-order! Oh, my God.
-I need to be on
the best-seller list, y'all.
-It's going to happen.
That's all it takes.
-Daddy got to pay that mortgage.
-Exactly.
I want to talk about "Pose,"
too, while you're here.
You have so many projects.
This is the final season
of "Pose."
-Yes.
-But you kind of always planned
this out to be
the final season, correct?
-Well, I didn't plan anything.
[ Laughter ]
The creators, Steven Canals and
Ryan Murphy and Brad Falchuk,
you know, they always intended
for the story to end
when the antiretroviral drugs
came out.
And that was '96.
And, you know, there wasn't
really a limit,
but as we told the story,
you know,
they realized,
"Oh, we're there."
And, you know, the show
is too important
to continue it
just because it's a hit.
-Yeah.
-It matters too much.
You know, this season is --
I think it's exceptional.
You know, I keep saying, you
know, just for me personally,
you know, I got to use "Pose"
and Pray Tell as a proxy,
you know, for my healing.
-Oh, interesting.
-And, you know,
I've been saying,
if I don't ever
do anything else --
and I'm already doing
a lot of other things --
but if I don't ever do anything
in my life -- else in my life,
I will have done it, you know?
It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've said everything
I've needed to say,
and now it's time to tell
a different story.
Now I get to tell a different
story, and I'm excited about it.
-I love you, bud.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Billy Porter in "Pose."
Take a look.
-I loved you.
And I'm not ashamed of
what you once meant to me,
but you're asking me
to step away from the church.
-No, no, no, no, the church
stepped away from me.
And I'm not the only one.
Every year I watch hundreds
of kids flock to the city,
looking for what they lost after
the church threw them away.
That's what your church d--
♪♪
That's what your church did.
To me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Billy Porter!
Amazing. Amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The final season of "Pose" airs
Sundays at 10:00 p.m. on FX.
Look for the music!
Look for the book!